[Music]
our intelligent machines a threat free
will is free well for a purpose and
quantum mechanics seems to be
inconsistent with itself I'm saying
there is some hidden beauty in these
things but it's not after the Big Bang
it's before it
[Music]
the current view of the origin of the
universe is that it started with this
Big Bang and the universe expanded and
slowed down a bit and then it started
doing what we call the exponential
expansion which people refer to as the
result of dark energy whatever dark
energy is now it's actually the case
that in 1917 two years after an Stein
introduced his general theory of
relativity he put in a term into the
equations an extra little piece which
was called the cosmological constant I
introduced this in order to have a
universe which was static and he knew
that by putting this extra term in the
cosmological constant he could have a
model of the universe which stayed the
same all the time which is what he
wanted however he realized this was a
mistake because the universe was
observed to be expanding and he when he
clearly took that on board he rejected
his cosmological constant however it
turns out that he was right all along in
that this term that he introduced has an
effect which causes what we see now as
an extra expansion that the universe is
doing is sort of expansion slowed down
and then it started to increase in this
exponential way which is referred to
well they call it exponential expansion
but it's referred to as a result of
maybe what they call dark energy
now dark energy doesn't mean anything
it's a term I think it's a bad term
because the first of all it's called
dark and that would mean it would look
dark but it's invisible you look
straight through it
it's not really dark it's not even
really energy because energy according
to Einstein is equivalent to mass and
mass attracts so if it's really energy
in the ordinary sense it would pull the
universe
back together but it doesn't that pushes
it away so it's a strange kind of energy
it's not really but it is exactly what
his cosmological constant would do so
the universe is doing this exponential
expansion now in current cosmology
there's also something else which is
introduced just after the Big Bang looks
just like this other exponential
expansion but it occurred according to
theory in the first well it's hard to
say is exactly but think of a number
with 32 digits a big number take the
inverse the reciprocal of that very tiny
number that fraction of a second that
ridiculously small fraction of a second
this thing called inflation is supposed
to have taken place that is supposed to
explain various things which are hard to
explain in cosmology in other ways let's
not go into that but the current view is
that the universe didn't just start with
a Big Bang there was the Big Bang then
there was this inflation then it
suddenly turned off and then we had this
more sedate expansion and then we see
this exponential expansion again now now
in my view this original inflation
didn't happen but there is something
very much like it which is the
exponential expansion of what I'm
calling a previous Eon now what is an
eon this is a term I was glad to see
when I look up in the dictionary didn't
really designate any definite number of
years it's an indefinite term so I was
glad to pick up on the term what an eon
to me is a Eowyn that is it is our Eon
started with the Big Bang no inflation
universe expanded and then you have this
exponential expansion which goes on
indefinitely that's one year I claimed
there was another Eon before ours and
it's exponential expansion in this
remote future was what looks to us like
the
inflation that we seem to see
but it's not after the Big Bang it's
before it now that's a crazy idea but
this idea is crazy and often we find
that ideas seem crazy turn out actually
to be right so the idea the hope here is
that this crazy idea does turn out to be
right
well first of all I come from
mathematics and physics and that's not
the usual mathematics it's partly
understanding what we mean by
understanding in mathematics and I
believe that there are clear indications
that what we mean by understanding in
mathematics is not something which can
be done by a computer so this is the
common view is that computers - can do
anything the brain can do or at least
imitate what the brain does whether it
has the same feelings as a brain there's
a separate question but I'm trying to
argue that it can't even imitate what we
do we know that computers can do
incredible things they can play chess
obviously well and so on and so on but
they don't understand that they're doing
and one can make arguments that is the
case that understanding something
understanding the output of a computer
for instance is completely different
from producing calculations which the
computer comes up with uses in its
operations so mathematical understanding
I believe is not something that you
could do with a computer secondly
physics well I can't come to this from a
problem which has been bugging me and I
may say was one of the things about
curing for a long time still bugged in
minds up to the end of his life as far
as I'm aware which has to do with
quantum mechanics in quantum mechanics
seems to be inconsistent with itself you
have two procedures which contradict
each other one is the evolution of the
system evolution wavefunction which is a
good trading this equation which is a
deterministic equation which is
continuous and the other is what you do
with it
which is making a measurement in quantum
mechanics and you can see the two things
are incompatible with the
now usually physicists or philosophers
who discuss this topic try to make sort
of interpret things in a way that makes
sense to them to me it's quite different
the problem is that there's something
wrong
the quantum mechanics cannot hold at all
levels
now the outrageous point of view that I
expressed with regard to consciousness
is that first of all you'll have to find
something which could possibly be non
computational and could not be imitated
even very approximately by a computer
and secondly well what nerve is it if
there is such a thing I take the view
that rather different from IANS that
that more or less the physical world is
out there and you're trying to
understand how consciousness coming back
from it not that the physical world is a
feature of our consciousness it's we
have to understand how consciousness
could come about from physical actions
and if they're all computational thank
you so it's got to be taking advantage
of this missing part and you see people
think it's quite not rageous this often
many many people do because they think
well i'm not only am i saying that
quantum mechanics at a large level is
important in operations the conscious
brain but also it's not just that it's
where quantum mechanics goes wrong which
is important that's the key thing but if
you've got to find a place where it goes
wrong then you have to find that it goes
right for up to that point and to find
structures in the brain which could
possibly support this kind of quantum
activity at that level is pretty
outrageous so the question is where does
that come from well neurons
did he seemed to me you're going to have
much go there the way people talk about
the brain but since you lose all your
information isn't quantum mechanics very
rapidly
you need some structures but below that
so I'm talking about I got this idea
from Stuart Hameroff and we've been
working together for a long time because
he's interested in looking putting
people to sleep that's his professional
activity and he's also interested in
what he's doing when he puts people to
sleep which is to
his view is this microtubules is a tiny
little nanoscale of tubes which inhabit
most cells not only in animals but also
in plants and you have to understand how
they can have a special role to play in
let me put something else proteins
nanometers across can you expect
obedience where they are we're getting
there in almost all cells in the body so
how many people say well why isn't your
liver conscious if that's what it is of
course that's not the whole story it
can't be
let me say more about what the story
probably is and this is fairly fairly
recent there are a couple of I'm talking
about experiments people have done he's
a couple of experiments one was
specifically on microtubules which have
been made by an Indian and a ban-ban de
peaje who was working in Japan and I
works in MIT and what he does is he put
electrodes in individual microtubules in
extraordinary technological feat and and
you put an alternating voltage and it's
certain very specific frequencies
suddenly they become very very
conductive now this conduction is
something quite unlike ordinary kind of
conduction because the longer the
microtubule the the actual conductance
is the same it's not as though it's a
resistance which would increase the long
tube is but the resistance is actually
goes down slide it when it's longer
moreover it's independent of the
temperature goes right up to body
temperature there's no problem that so
there's something going on of a quantum
mechanical character in microtubules is
something which is understood in terms
of ordinary classical processes not
directly anything to do with
consciousness it's not saying it and it
shouldn't be because this is a far too
low-level consciousness would have to on
the scheme that I'm trying to argue for
it would require many many microtubules
and they would have to be organized to
in some way so that there is enough mass
displacement I should say that it
depends on very specific ideas which
come from quantum mechanics and the
limitations of quantum mechanics I mean
I would really do respect to attempt to
solve that that issue of consciousness
it doesn't seem to me to be in the
country which most people are deeply
concerned with which is why is it like
what why is it like something and to
live in the world as we do in to
experience the world as we do every day
I'm not addressing this question I know
people that people say you know why
aren't you dressing the real problems
because that's I have nothing to say
[Music]
which seems to me that it's something
outside what you could do with a
computer you see there is an issue to
some extent being with Ian on this it's
there is an issue about how you could
solve a problem this is to say what is
it that's different about internal
feelings and so on from the workings of
the world now if you believe as I do
there is to do with the world it's not
something you know mysteriously we have
maybe you could make it in the lab I
have no argument against that but it
wouldn't be simply a computer it's gotta
be something which takes advantage of
this gap in quantum mechanics so as you
get to a certain level and then instead
of following the route which the
Schrodinger equation tells you if you do
one thing or another and this is part of
what happens when you make a measurement
in quantum mechanics so there's a choice
that you think makes now this process
which I'm regarding is something very
physical at the moment is every time
that happens is associated with an
element of what I can call well I'm
calling proto consciousness so it's so
is it it is a pan psychic sort of give
it like what iam is saying in a way but
it's not matter it's to do with the
process of these alternatives resolving
either one or the other
I think the I mean with the question is
is can our intelligent machines a threat
they shall have a problem with a
question because I certainly don't think
with my definition of a machine
basically it would be a
computer-controlled robot or something
like that and my position for various
reasons is that such devices would not
be intelligent so we don't have
intelligent machines and on this
criterion we will never have them we
might have devices if they and I'm not
saying that you couldn't have a device
of some kind which could be conscious
which could perhaps achieve I'm not
saying we couldn't have a machine which
could be conscious and could perhaps
achieve things of intelligence that we
can do I'm just saying that they won't
be computer controlled devices that
computers as such wouldn't have
intelligence and the kind of Reason I
would have for saying this is that
computers well they are by definition
computers and they do what are called
computations and these notions of
computations or algorithms were put
forward very clearly by Alan Turing in
other logicians and there are also
strong arguments that logicians such as
cheering I may say and girdle they put
forward arguments which basically tell
us that understanding is not something
that a computational device is capable
of now the way I look at it is that
understanding is indeed something that
computational device can't do and
understanding is something that requires
consciousness and consciousness is
something we don't understand yet it's
something which I think there's strong
reason to believe is not a product of
computational action there's something
quite different going on and we see both
things in the brain and we don't see it
we believe and have evidence for the
part of the brain which is back here not
the cerebrum which I'm talking about the
cerebellum which has about half as many
near
half as many which is quite a lot as the
cerebrum has it has far more
interconnections between these neurons
and it appear apparently is completely
unconscious and actions you may learn to
do something play the piano or play
tennis or something like this and then
when you the skills are developed your
cerebellum cerebellum takes over and
allows you to do them well sophisticated
over all things what strategy will use
what kind of feeling will you put into
your playing and that kind of thing
whereas the mechanics of it all is taken
over by entirely unconscious activity
now I can quite accept that the action
of the cerebellum could be may be
mimicked by a computer there are lots of
things probably in neural and
neuroscience which is which is
adequately described by computational
device but whatever consciousness is is
something quite different and it's
something extremely important if it
weren't important in our actions it
wouldn't have evolved so it's evolved
for some reason and this reason gives us
qualities which we can allow us to do
things that we can't do purely
consciously purely unconsciously and it
also has something to do with setting up
the unconscious device it's a bit like
the way computers work how does a
computer out of not how it works but how
how do we use a computer we use a
computer you have some idea you have
some thing you wanted to do you can
reduce it to a calculation of some kind
put it on the machine it does the
calculation calculation the answer comes
out and then you decide what that
calculation means the meaning is not
something which is part of the
calculation it's external to the
calculation so the claim I would make is
that we don't have intelligent machines
not only that we will never have
machines which are genuinely intelligent
if machine means what I'm saying it
means a computationally control device
we might have things which somehow maybe
we'll figure out what's going on in
there and maybe we'll have some kind of
device which does it I mean I don't
think see it's anywhere within what we
can envisage at the moment maybe some
latter-day Dave Frankenstein will build
something like that but I don't think
it's a threat to us well I've always
been troubled after one or the other
and there are experiments people do
which show that some part of them you
try to make a conscious choice about
something and there's some evidence of a
buildup of signals which tells you that
some part of the brain knew which choice
you were going to make but all these
things not what you'd use free well for
you see it's not quite particularly
because I had experiences when I was
young so let me give you this my younger
brother used to there's this game
scissors and paper stone you know that
way and there are three things you do
atoms the scissors with the paper either
stone on you and you don't reveal it
until the last minute and he used to
wallop me at this game consistently and
I thought I was using free will you see
to decide which I'm going to do how does
he know you know is it some mystery
predicting the future or something so
what I did is I went to a table of
logarithms you know it's only about
seven or something he was spending about
five I can't remember and I use the
table of logarithms and I just worked it
out you know um seven means Stone eight
means scissors or whatever it was and
then all the way through you see so I
take these digits and I would play this
game reading off the digits and then I
broke even so it was as though my free
will was not really much of a free will
usually I was just doing which sort of
came easily to me at the moment and that
kind of thing
okay maybe you could make predictions
about what people are gonna guess next
and it's not really a free will is free
will for a purpose you're doing
something because it means something not
just because it's a round of choice so
but I I don't know I will always be in
two minds about that and you see physics
you might think well it's all determined
and so what you do now is determined by
what happened yesterday
if you knew all the details of how all
the particles are moving but this isn't
quite true as things go because you have
this curious thing within quantum
mechanics
you have the collapse of the
wavefunction that the Schrodinger
equation chugs along and says what's
going to happen suddenly it doesn't it's
something doesn't it jumps to this or
that and people usually talk this and
talk about this in terms of measurements
my view is that it's happening all the
time and you have just lots of particles
and when they get up to a certain mass
level then it does one thing or another
and whenever those choices are made you
see Stuart Hameroff and I have built up
this idea about consciousness and we
consider that consciousness comes about
when these collapse wavefunction things
happen now the question is does it
collapse in a way which is random that's
there that's the way physics works now
you consider it to be quite random well
if it's maybe entangled with all sorts
of other things and the decision about
what it makes this of that has some kind
of content to it some mental content
which is not altogether random and that
would be where the freewill plays its
role so you know maybe that's controlled
by some deterministic laws which go
deeper than the laws we know now or is
there some actual freedom you know what
happens in the operation of the universe
I'm not making any sitting on one side
or the other here it just seems to me to
look quite appealing that there is
something in a choice which is not
actually determined by the other laws of
physics and it's it's something more
much more subtle than than being random
it would have to be something which has
a gong goes beyond computation and
that's what I claim is involved when we
make conscious choices but whether it's
how free it is I don't know I wouldn't
like to make a strong claim on that but
there's room there's room for some kind
of a thing that you might call free will
there yes
[Music]
well there's quantum mechanics you see
now quantum mechanics consists of two
parts you see this is basically I learnt
from Dirac about the puzzles of quantum
mechanics I think it was partly because
I dozed off at the beginning it wasn't
actually in my mind wandered a certain
way this is his very first lecture in
direct selection no I didn't know you
see it was right at the beginning and he
was talking about the superposition
principle they see if you have a
particle and if this one state of the
particles it's here another state of the
particles it's here then you can have
States where it's here and here at the
same time so you can see particles can
be in two places at once crazy but
that's how quantum mechanics works then
he took a piece of chalk and I think he
broke it in two and say look the chalk
is now imagined it's here and here at
the same time this was the point my mind
wandered you see because he gave some
explanation I think sort of I think the
faintest idea what it was I just
remembered something about the word
energy coming into it and I'm worried
about then ever since you see so why is
it that you don't have pieces of chalk
and in two places at once people in two
places at once and all that and this is
a big problem in quantum mechanics so my
view was that quantum mechanics can't be
quite right and Einstein had that view
yes he had a similarly yes yes this is a
little bit more specific because it has
to do with why is it not right but that
took me longer to think about that but
the view is that it can't be quite right
and the way in which is not quite right
has to be taken advantage of by the
brain so this was the idea and I had and
I wrote this book the emperor's new mind
I thought probably it would disappear
without trace but then Stephen Hawking
had written his book on the brief
history of time and he have got
what's-his-name Carl Sagan who writer
before word so I thought actually gets
done Billy decent to write a foreword
then maybe so I got Martin Gardner so I
I had no idea what Martin Martin
Gardner's views when he says yes
agree with you he says so he was happy
to write forward and then I thought well
it's probably won't disappear without
trace know the difference between the
two books is that beef history of time
the Hawking's about that big and Rogers
handy-dandy quick primer for
consciousness is about Pathak it's got
pictures thing yes but it's interesting
is this too lot of people hated it yes
they did oh gosh yet that I was making a
series on consciousness at the time and
again my whole life has been mentioning
you and people going like this yeah
because they they the chrism was that
all Roger has done is taken a mystery
and wrapped it in enigma and said there
you go taking two things we didn't
understand and say because we don't
understand these two things they must be
the same thing that's not the argument
at all they haven't read the book no
that's true it's true but the thing is
you see I had no idea what the answer
was so I wrote the book thinking that by
the time I had to learn some newer
physiology and that sort of thing by the
time I love that bit I would see where
there could be something going on in the
brain see the argument had to be that it
had to be some effect where gravity
comes in and I had no idea at that time
it didn't seem to me no propagation had
any chance of being the answer and the
thing is you see I was hoping that this
book would be read by young people
trying to learn about science and so on
most of the letters I got from people
from old retired people and those were
the people who had time to read the book
I guess but anyway not just old retired
people one person who did read the book
with Stuart Hameroff yes in Stuart
Hameroff his day job is to put people
and maybe in the night 200 put people to
sleep reversibly in other words you give
them general general anesthetics when
they have operations and unlike most of
his colleagues who were just as capable
of putting people to sleep and waking
them up afterwards they didn't seem to
worry as much as he did about what they
were actually doing yeah so this point
was what do the general artists
and aesthetics act on and his view was
that they acts on these things called
microtubules and so he sent me a letter
and you said well think missing from
your argument is you haven't mentioned
microtubules and I thought microtubules
I get lots of letters from lots
nutty people UCF oh gosh it's another
one but then I looked it up and I saw
the yeah they're real I should know I
should have learned about them and these
are little tiny tubes and I thought the
chance of preserving quantum coherence
at that level was much much greater than
but also in just the last year or two a
lot more people are coming around to
this idea because the problem was always
people said but can you maintain quantum
states in the brain because the brain is
a noisy messy and warm place which is
generally not good for content generally
if we want to do anything with quantum
mechanics we we buy a truckload of
liquid nitrogen and freeze the entire
place down and then we start we they and
some people didn't like it but in the
last two years a lot of new people are
starting because they've realized
actually they can find different quantum
stuff in the brain where they didn't
expect it so so Rogers detractors are
all feeling bit peeved if you want to
know whether something is true or not
then your aesthetic judgment can be very
important it's not that it's it's a
criterion for truth I mean it may be
wrong it may be right and the criterion
has to be in mathematics whether you can
prove it or not whether you can
establish if it's true or not but beauty
is a guide you can say is it more likely
to be true if I take this route well I
sometimes say well if it were true would
that be beautiful or would it not but
it's not a guide in the sense that you
say is it doesn't it doesn't doesn't
affect whether it's true or not
it doesn't affect well let's talk about
physics because that's a little
different now in physics I think it is a
guide again and I think well Dirac's
comment is one of the most
well I think the one I'm more familiar
with is when he somebody asked him how
does he find his equation for the
electron and he said when I found this I
knew I was right but he said I have a
keen sense of the beauty beautiful and
when I found this equation I knew I was
right well you see it's something about
how things fit together and you see this
thing relates and brings out things that
you didn't know before combined together
and and you could see a sense of beauty
comes about and it gives him more
credence it's not a guide to whether
it's right or not okay that in the
physics that comes from the experiments
in mathematics comes from whether you
can prove it or not whether it turns out
to be true or not but it's a guide and I
think I would always call it a guide and
not necessarily well there was something
deeper than that because why is it a
guide you might say why is it more
likely to be right or not and I think I
would find it very troublesome if we
found some one theory of physics which
works incredibly well the deep level is
hideously ugly I would say that one of
the things about string theory for
instance I mean one might say and I
think Sabina said this that so the
trouble with it is people say it's a
beautiful theory and that's what guided
people into kept people in this subject
it's true that it kept people in the
subject because it had an effect on
mathematics which beautiful results came
out of mathematics but as a physical
theory I always regarded as hideous it's
not beautiful at all it's the
mathematics involved is it's elegant in
many places but when you think of it as
a physical theory you know you're
combining that you know you've got these
extra dimensions some of them a tiny as
some of them a huge sometimes you get
different numbers that have been
dimensions mixed up together in the same
theory and it doesn't hang together as a
physical scheme yet it may have elements
of it which are beautiful now if it was
a beautiful physical theory as well I
would have taken it much more seriously
it's not just that we pick up the things
that are more beautiful and therefore
they're more successful well the you
know clever people like to work with
things that are beautiful and therefore
they're more successful
it's not just things of that nature I
think there is something else which is
important and that in theories in
physics which turn out to be correct
there is something well what is it I
mean is it just that they apply very
broadly the different things and that in
the sense is beautiful in its sense in
itself or is there something else in it
and I think there is it's a bit hard to
put ones finger on it
I'd certainly don't go along with what I
mean Herrmann vows supposed to have made
some comment about you know when beauty
and truth come into conflict he would
choose beauty every time I mean it's
more kind of an emotional thing that you
also partly that beauty comes up later
you don't notice it's beautiful I mean
the theory looks ugly at first because
you don't see all the connections you
don't see the right way to phrase it
and then when you put it together and
suddenly it seems that you the beauty of
it is revealed now I'm saying there is
some hidden beauty in these things which
reveal them so we can reveal itself only
when you see it at a deeper level now is
this just us being something okay we
feel happier when we understand things
better
I'm not sure is it just simplicity or
because in the things you said it seemed
like perhaps it was when something is
simple that it looks more beautiful than
something that's long and lots of terms
or is it that it's it leads to other
things when you said that it makes
connections that is it those things that
I guess call them I think there's
something useful something unexpected
simplicity is involved if something is
that you didn't expect to be simple or
connected and that gives you an overall
picture of what's going on and that
makes you that gives us an aesthetic
attraction
[Music]
I should say that also I've written on
occasion about reality as three
different possible kinds of worlds one
of these is the physical world which we
experience tables and chairs and what
makes them tick and so on one is the
mathematical world which is very much
basic to how we presently understand how
the physical world operates and the
third is the mental world which has to
do with how we perceive and so on now
I'm taking this discussion to be
primarily about the physical world so
let me not leave aside those other
questions
however mathematics since it plays such
an important role in how we understand
the physical world I have to say
something in relation to that too
also let me say I completely agree that
often I agree with Hillary that often
physicists in particular are very
arrogant and make statements that they
that we almost know everything and I
certainly don't agree with that point of
view I think we're quite a long way from
understanding but you have to bear in
mind we do understand an awful lot and a
lot of what we do understand comes from
thinking about things theorizing about
things and I think it's useful to think
about well first of all ancient ideas
about how what caused a night you see
the Sun going across the sky and people
used to think that it was attached to
some crystalline glow or something like
that and it took a long time for people
to be persuaded that in fact the earth
was rotating because if it's rotating
surely you'd feel the the motion and so
on and so Galileo had to explain no no
you wouldn't
it's the laws are such that if you're in
uniform motion
you don't feel it and that's a crucial
feature and so now people quite
willingly accept that it's the earth
rotating when you see the Sun going you
know no no the earth is really going
round and the Sun is is it's not the
thing that you should be thinking knobs
are going around the earth and so on so
these ideas of chain
changed and they've given us a much
better picture of what's going out in
the world now I think the theory of
gravity is a very good example how
things I mean when you can explain the
motions of planets and stars motions of
planets and of the Earth from the moon
and so on in relation to the Sun using
his theory of universal gravity he had
perhaps about three decimal places to
work with and he produced a theory some
people would say well he was saw that
what how the thing did and he produced
the best theory you could to fit the
data
the same theory he'll right up until
well well into the nineteenth century
and discrepancies were not fought
originally to be anything anything wrong
with Newton's theory but I should the
point I want to make here is that one
had something like four more decimal
places already out there in the world so
it wasn't that he was fitting the
observations to the best theory you
could thought of it's really a theory
which does drive the world okay now we
know that Einstein had a better theory
and it's important to realize that an
Stein's theory incorporates Newton's it
isn't a contradiction to Newton's theory
it's something which goes beyond it it
explains what goes on the circumstances
beyond what Newton's theory could deal
with when motions are first well you
have to understand the motions in
relation to the speed of light and so on
but then out there you get another four
decimal places well know that another
seven decimal places so if something
like it's accurate to something like one
part in 10 to the 14 now this precision
was nothing known to Einstein whatsoever
yet he I'm not sure he even knew about
the seventh whether whether he's paid
much attention to very union of mercury
isn't clear at all but using his his
theoretical understanding he was able to
develop a theory which was far more
precise then in fact lots of the
predictions were things he had no idea
when people ever see like the bending of
light and how you can actually see the
curvature of space-time direct
things like this also whenever you drive
your car especially to get here if you
use a GPS that is using very very
precise aspects of Einstein's general
theory of relativity that's out there in
the world it's something it's a it's
describing a reality which is there and
I think that one has to face up to this
it's not just how we look at it it's not
ok our views of what's going on change
and certainly it's not a final view I'm
sure there will be developments beyond
this but we have to appreciate that
there is a reality out there which the
theory gives us and I'm just trying to
say that ok there's particular aspect
there lots of other things
the reality is outside us it's beyond us
is out there in the world it's not
created by us it is that your position
Roger ultimately everything is knowable
well knowable one has to be cautious
about the first yeah I don't know what
we can know but I have no reason to see
that basic the basic rules the basic
picture of the world is something no
more I have no reason against that ok of
course it's very different from from
even the views what we have now I mean
that's clear
yeah there are things in physics which
tell us that the world is it has is a
very different has a very different
character in many ways from even our
best theories now
[Music]
well there are other things going on too
because there's twister theory now you
see that's I don't usually talk about it
in interviews because it's it hard to
explain but that's an idea which I had a
lot of people working on when I was it -
and graduate students had a lot of
graduate students and many of them
worked on twister theory which gives a
different different point of view of
hard to do view physics if you like see
usually we think of space time and space
is three dimensions and then time is
another one so you've got this space
time which is a four dimensional
structure and the basic thing it's made
of are these little points we call them
events you see no no dimension in space
no dimension in time the but you see
like that those are the points in
space-time with events they see you
twist the theory that's not the basic
structure the basic thing is basically
but something like a photon it's it goes
along with the speed of light and you
can identify the points because you have
no family of them going through that
point it's sort of - it's a kind of
geometry which turns the ordinary way of
looking at physics inside out some
things are more difficult to do
something is a lot easier to do and
what's a lot easier is to describe feels
like the Maxwell feel for the radiation
the gravitational field in fact
gravitational field well there's a story
here you see photons can spin
left-handed or right-handed and you can
describe the wave function of a
left-handed or right-handed one and
usually you add them together because
they both spins combined together to
give you the linear polarizations and
things you know polarized glasses you
have they let the light through one way
and not the other way and these and you
add to what right-handed and left-handed
together to get the linear polarized
then they're different ways of doing it
anyway that's the way photons work now
we see in twister theory it's very
peculiar you have a two different
formula one which works for the
right-hand and one which works the
left-hand and for the gravitons that is
the particle of gravity if you like
again you do this but you see with
gravity you want to make it fit in with
einstein's theory so change your space
spacetime is changed by the gravity and
then you find you can do it and you can
do it for the left-handed ones but not
for the right-handed ones and this was a
great puzzle to me because what twister
theories got a twist type that's left
and lies are not quite the same in the
theory and you could do the left-handed
ones are not the right elements and I
used to call this the googly problem
because in cricket you see a ball a
cricket ball and if it spins what's the
thing called a leg break then if it
spins left-handed that's a leg break if
you're very clever not many people can
do it you can make it spin looking as
though it's got left-handed but actually
spins right-handed and that's what's
called a googly so we call this the
googly problem because you're trying to
get the right-handed graviton in the
framework which does the left-handed one
and that was a stumbling block which
took about 40 years and only fairly
recently I had an idea with some help
from Michael idea who have got ideas
from my doctor and I had sort of part of
the idea and I can quite understand the
other part which he explained and even
then he took another five years to make
it work but I think it works so this is
a way of describing physics in this
unusual way and if you can spin both the
right and left you can do also the
particle interactions the strong
interactions and the weak interactions
and you can put the lot right and the
left together
and I haven't done any of this but it's
a potential way of looking at physics in
a completely different way well some of
its being looked at already if people
people have picked up on twister theory
but not on this latest idea they use it
for scattering problems massless
particles and things but not to the
extent that this would be a global
theory which should be able to translate
physics into this other language and it
has sort of features which I appeal to
me very much
one of them is the use of complex
numbers you see usually people think of
numbers or the integers 1 2 3 4 our
fractions which are 7 over 5 or whatever
it is or real numbers which write my
decimal which goes off to infinity so
you tend to think of physics in terms of
real numbers they're called real numbers
they're not real in the ordinary sense
of real but but they're real but they're
no more real than some other kinds of
numbers but the things called imaginary
numbers or complex numbers are things
were you allowed to take the square root
of minus 1 and that's the key thing you
allowed to have a thinking called I and
that's the square root of minus 1 once
you put that into it you have a whole
new but not that new it was many
centuries ago when the idea was
introduced but it's a whole different
way of looking at the world and the
thing about it is quantum mechanics
already looks at the world that way
quantum mechanics the states in quantum
mechanics involve these complex numbers
so the idea is that you bring that kind
of complex number geometry into the real
world in the classical world and it's
somehow the quantum class will get a
little mixed up and it's a different way
of looking at things and there's very
beautiful mathematics in the complex
world if you like which you don't see in
the real world and it's and it's
something which when I was an undergrad
and mathematics undergraduate I was
absolutely stunned by the magic there is
in these complex complex number means
got a real number and imagine your
number together in the same number and
the algebra and the analysis and all
that stuff and the geometry of these
numbers has an elegance which you don't
see in the real numbers AMA true so it
always struck me as you know wouldn't it
be nice if somehow that was what
governed the world and that's what
twister theory does it gives you a
complex number picture real and
imaginary together picture of the world
which involves quantum ideas as well as
classical answers but the new idea where
the googley problem seems to be solved
I haven't had a chance to look at it
very seriously
so that's your next challenge exploring
this
[Music]